if effective means you need four doses
in less than two years and it still
doesn't control contraction or
transmission of the disease if that's
what effective means what a safe mean
effective obviously doesn't mean
effective i'm thinking safe might not
mean safe either so at the point you
realize somebody's telling me oh yeah
this is safe you should get it they
didn't do very well with effective and i
can tell that myself because i'm being
told i need my fourth dose at that point
i'm not saying this is a good thing but
i am saying at that point you should
stop listening to the people who told
you it was effective because they were
wrong they have not acknowledged that
they were wrong they haven't explained
how that happened or what you should
think now right you should not listen to
them and you should say well it would be
great if they were an institution or a
publication i could go to that would
tell me the truth doesn't exist so maybe
i should start looking around for people
who have left a record of what they've
thought over the course of the pandemic
and i should start looking for people
for whom that record suggests that they
do understand what's going on